so so so you're from Chicago so what was
that like it was fine you know I spent a
summer in Chicago oh really so when I
was there I worked in a comic shop and
one day this guy came in and he was
buying a bunch of t-shirts and they were
all Firefly t-shirts so of course I
asked him I was like hey do you like the
show Firefly or something and he was
like yeah I'm a big fan
and so I'm ringing him up at the
register and guess who walks in none
other than Nathan Fillion Yeah right
good the whole time I was actually
helping the brother of Nathan Fillion
that's so funny so I I'm really into the
season of homeland do you watch
nope well I don't get Showtime I used to
but then the only show I watched was Ray
Donovan so that I found out that it was
cheaper to actually buy each episode ala
carte on Amazon and so then I got my
Apple TV and then through the Amazon app
I'm able to just purchase each episode
and it's it works that way my ex he
loves redone oven um kind of looks like
Liev Schreiber
oh wow he must be super handsome so do
you want another drink
oh no no I'm good thank you okay so um
you know I should probably get going I
have a busy day tomorrow
oh okay well let me walk you to your car
oh I'm just parked right outside oh okay
um you know it was a pleasure meeting
you thank you so much Edgar uh it's
Elliot actually what oh never mind
uh you should do this again sometime um
how about next week maybe just go ahead
and text me okay okay bye okay okay
so how'd it go awesome best date I've
ever had
she definitely likes me yeah I don't
think she does yeah she had this look in
her eyes you know check ah yeah I saw
that look I want to jump your bones yeah
yeah yeah you know that look yeah dude
you ever seen that you probably haven't
seen that before
how's your blue balls it's really really
blue I mean the drink yeah oh yeah can I
have another
sure